MIN-MIN LIANG: My
name is Min-Min Liang.
I'm from Taiwan.
And I'm a Chinese
lecturer at MIT.
And I graduated my
college in Taiwan.
And I came here to
the United States
to get my master's
degree at Harvard.
And after the master program,
I went to UPenn for the Ph.D.
That's where I started
teaching Chinese,
because I have a
scholarship there.
And even though my major
is Chinese literature,
but I find teaching Chinese
is really fun and stimulating.
And my total years of
teaching is 21 years.
And I find it interesting,
because every school
is different.
And so I constantly have
to adapt my strategy
to a different
group of students.
And I find that's very exciting.
It's not things so mundane.
It's so routine.
In that way, there's
a routine there,
but you have to
change up according
to the audience, the group.